To some of you have rightly and accurately
pointed out to me that suddenly Florida's
corona virus cases have started to decline,
California's corona virus cases don't seem
to be spiking the way the trajectory suggested.
And I started to look into this.
And indeed, it is true.
If you look at Florida, their cases have started
to drop off.
But it just so happens that Florida stopped
testing.
This is no conspiracy theory.
This is what they announced they were going
to do because of the hurricane.
Hurricane SARS.
As Donald Trump has struggled to say, look
at this article from NPR from July twenty
ninth saying Florida will pause.
Corona virus testing due to impending storm.
Now, it didn't happen all at once.
In all of the counties.
So we are still seeing thousands of cases
a day from Florida.
But because different counties, as the hurricane
worked its way through the state, stopped
testing, the numbers of tests went down dramatically.
And we can sort of turn to Donald Trump's
favorite phrase here.
If you don't test, you don't find cases.
And that's true.
The article saying, quote, After the state's
testing sites close Thursday evening, that's
last Thursday, they won't reopen until at
least Tuesday morning.
That's yesterday.
That's according to Candi Simms of the Florida
Department of Health in Broward County.
So what do we do?
Well, one thing we can look at is ICU usage.
And you can see that Florida ICU usage hit
100 percent in the last week of July and it's
still there.
You can actually go over 100 percent in that.
You can start to convert non ICU spaces in
hospitals to temporary ICU.
But Florida has been stuck at 100 percent
ICU usage for days.
This is very, very bad.
And I'm getting more and more people saying,
can we even trust the numbers now?
Can we trust the case numbers?
Can we even trust the death numbers right
now?
And this is a real concern.
Now, part of the concern generally comes from
the change that happened from July 15th into
July 16th, where hospitals were mandated to
stop reporting directly to the CDC and instead
to the Department of Health and Human Services.
There are open questions as to if and to what
degree that has influenced numbers in specific
states, though we know why the case numbers
are going down.
Florida is one example.
They stopped testing because of the hurricane.
Let's look at California.
California now is admitting that for days
they've been underreporting case numbers.
The explanation is still not totally clear.
And maybe by later today or tomorrow, we will
know more about it.
But a message appeared on California's COBA
19 dashboard, which said, quote, Due to the
issues with the state's electronic laboratory
system, these data represent an underreporting
of actual positive cases.
California's top health official, Dr. Mark
Gallie, said, quote, Over the past few days,
the state system, we've discovered some discrepancies.
So we're still waiting on more information.
But when you look at the globe, the national
case numbers, and you see that they seem to
at least have stopped increasing.
Understand that two of the major case centers,
Florida and California, are underreporting
cases.
One, because they are there.
They've stopped testing because of a weather
event.
California for some unknown reason that they've
discovered discrepancies.
And yet, even with Florida reducing testing,
even with California underreporting, we still
at 54000 new cases yesterday.
We still had almost 49000 new cases on Monday.
So a few different thoughts on this.
Cases aren't really declining.
They've kind of leveled off at the national
level.
But two states are underreporting.
And that would be a huge piece of why that
is.
So first off, at this point, it's very hard
to say for sure whether cases are still growing
nationally or have leveled off or what's going
on.
What we do know is that the big picture, the
sort of fundamentals of what's happening in
the country haven't really changed.
So we wouldn't really expect a huge decline
because there haven't been any big changes
in policy.
Now, it's conceivable that even without states
really changing policy, that people are seeing
the headlines and they're being more cautious.
That's possible.
It would take about fifteen or so days to
notice that.
And increasingly, deaths are going to be the
indicator to the extent that we can trust
them.
And if you look at the trend line in terms
of deaths, the seven day moving average, which
sort of smooths out those dips of reporting
that happen over the weekend, the death rate
rate than the death trends don't look good.
They may have maybe leveled off slightly,
but yesterday, again, we had nearly 15 hundred
deaths.
So it's too early to say.
And then you get to are there ways to cover
up deaths?
We know that there are you can mess with cause
of death.
You can do other other things.
So the important message, I think, is we're
in an area now where there is a question mark
around the accuracy of the data.
We don't have to go conspiratorial.
We don't have to make any definitive statements.
We can just say there are reasons to be skeptical
of the data.
Including that Florida stop testing in California
is underreporting.
So we are still at huge risk of even bigger
spikes when the United States got from, what
was it, 35000 cases a day, down to 20000.
Almost every state started reopening 20000
cases we still had, and many states saw that
as a license to open.
And we got all the way back up to 70000 cases
a day at one point about ten days ago.
What we can say for sure is widespread reopening
and ignoring risk factors and risky activities
and not wearing masks is going to create a
completely out of control spike.
And just look at some of the headlines from
the last 24 hours.
Teachers returned to a Georgia school district
last week.
260 employees have already gone home to quarantine.
Not good.
Dr. Foushee says if we don't get below 10000
cases a day before the fall, we will have
an even more insane explosion in the fall.
And that's still 10000 cases a day.
That would mean we need is like an 80 to 90
percent reduction to get down to 10000 cases
a day.
Clorox announces it will not have enough disinfecting
wipes until 2021, according to its CEO.
Twenty five people have been infected at a
Bible camp in Oregon when Corona virus subsided
in Israel.
Israel reopened schools.
It didn't go well and things are shutting
back down.
This is a real thing.
You know, when Trump says it's the invisible
enemy.
It's this dumb thing.
He keeps repeating the invisible scorch, nobody
telling him it's pronounced scourge.
OK, but in a sense, it can feel as though
it's not really there because it is invisible.
We see the results through our actions.
Our actions directly impact these numbers
to the extent that we get the real numbers.
And we need to be very cautious.
You know, I'm trying to take it in stride
in the sense that my I can only focus on my
sphere of influence.
I can't control what everybody in the country
does.
I can't control what the policy is.
I can ensure that I'm acting as responsibly
as possible.
And at least to you, I communicate what seems
to be responsible.
Our actions have consequences.
And if it's I can't think of a time where
it's been more clear than it is
right now.